Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmologische angelegenheiten
ja und das hier ist dann schon die einundachtzigste ausgabe unserer serie und heute hat's mich mal wieder in die ferne getrieben heute mich nach tübingen gefahren an die universität tübingen,
genauer bin ich jetzt gelandet am institut für astronomie und astrophysik,
und noch ein wenig genauer im zentrum für astro teilchen physik also ist schon etwa klar worum es heute vielleicht gehen könnte aber zunächst einmal begrüße ich meinen gesprächspartner nämlich klaus ferner für guten tag.
Ja wer ähm heute wollen wir mal ein wenig schauen was es denn
so mit der beobachtung des weltraum auf sich hat konkret möchte ich heute sprechen über,
großteil des gruppe im all und nochmal etwas genauer natürlich über das hotel weltraum teleskop was ja hier eigentlich so das wichtigste und bekannteste projekt ist was wir derzeit haben,
aber wie so meine art ist stark ich erstmal ein bisschen,
mit ihnen ein das würde mich natürlich sehr interessieren sind ja auch schon 'ne weile dabei.
Ja ist richtig ja.
Womit pfingsten anbieten.
Ah ja also ich hatte mich als schüler schon für die gastronomie interessiert ich hatte mir als quasi fünfzehnjähriger schüler ein eigenes teleskop gekauft von dem ersten selbst verdienten geld.
Warum.
Und warum wo kommt das her ja zu der zeit,
sich etwa dreizehn oder vierzehn jahre alt war äh haben mich meine eltern ins planetarium bochum geschleppt,
so das war das war die initial zündung gewesen das hat.
Schon vorbei sozusagen.
Ja das hat mich total fasziniert muss ich sagen das war wirklich die das wichtig.
Von welchem jahr reden wir jetzt so in etwa.
Das muss so neunzehnhundertsiebzig einundsiebzig gewesen sein zu apollo und fahrrad zeit.
Okay aber mondlandung war schon durch.
Die war erstmal schon durch aber aber nicht die letzte.
Ja da ging es also los und.
Das war doch schon so noch eine zeit wo das so ein paar jahre auch wirklich signifikante auswirkungen hatte also wo sie einfach das ganze weltraum thema in der gesellschaft an sich überhaupt erstmal sich so richtig verankert hat.
Ja das war so die zeit ende der sechziger anfang der siebziger jahre als die bemannten raum vater so ein riesen hype war,
und jeder dachte so anfang der siebziger jahre als das apollo programm zu ende ging jetzt geht's irgendwie weiter mit den nächsten mal mit den bemannten raum flügen oder werner von braun waren ja damals auch noch in
diensten der nasa gewesen und äh das ist ja dann alles ziemlich schnell zusammengeklappt anfang mitte der siebzig anfang mitte der siebziger jahre
dass dieser raumfahrt halt ziemlich schnell vorbei war und ich sag mal bis heute eigentlich immer noch vorbei ist das darf man vielleicht nicht jeden hören lassen aber.
Selbst und bin seit dieser zeit mit mantel so ein fan von bemannten weltraum fahrt
allerdings finde ich es relativ langweilig,
wenn diese raum verzogen um die erde kreisen in vierhundert kilometer höhe
was also wirklich als nächstes ansteht ist ein flugzeug maß also das ist etwas wo was ich gerne vielleicht auch nochmal erleben,
möchte aber ich fürchte das wird in den nächsten zwanzig dreißig jahren nicht passiert.
Ja wobei sich ja space x da ganz gut aufgestellt hat.
Stimmt.
Verspricht also halten kann.
Ja ich fürchte auch dass die finanziellen möglichkeiten dieser firma dann am ende doch nicht ausreichen werden um das zu stemmen also solange der jetzt von staatlicher seite.
Von der nasa oder eben auch von der isar seite nichts passiert also rein privat sowas zu,
glaube ich das wird nicht funktionieren.
Nochmal gucken solche gesellschaftlichen trends können sich ja auch schnell wieder ändern,
gerade dann wenn man es meistens nicht erwartet ich finde gerade so in der aktuellen debatte um klimawandel und er rettung ist jetzt auf einmal wieder ganz vorne,
ja die raumfahrt durchaus was zu bieten und na ja wenn die nadel mal wieder in die andere richtung schlägt dann kannst du auch mal ganz schnell gehen.
Könnte sein ne.
Na gut wissen wir nicht das war nicht.
Tja.
Wie ist es denn dann weitergegangen also mit nach dem teleskop.
Nach dem teleskop na ja das hat.
Sozusagen komplett verliebt ins all.
Ja erstmal also das hat bei mir so dann zwei drei jahre angedauert und allerdings so als ich etwa achtzehn jahre alt war war denn das in,
presse relativ erlernt und ja wie das damals so war mit achtzehn da hat man die möglichkeit oder die alternative entweder zur bundeswehr zu gehen oder sein ersatz dienst zu machen ich habe mich zunächst mal für die bundeswehr entschieden,
da war ich damals fünfzehn monate gewesen und als ich dann entlassen worden bin dann stand dann die frage,
auf dem tisch,
was studierst du denn jetzt aus ich wollte schon studieren auch naturwissenschaften das war schon klar dass es in die richtung geht aber so konkret was ich jetzt machen wollte war überhaupt nicht klar und ich habe mich tatsächlich dann erstmal für,
das fach chemie eingeschrieben bis ich dann nach einem semester merkte das ist nichts für dich,
ich fand also organische schienen wie das was man so in der schule macht es ist noch relativ leicht und übersichtlich aber dann ging es dann mit der anorganischen,
und anders rum mit der anorganischen chemie was noch relativ einfacher heute organischen chemie was dann schon ziemlich kompliziert und das hat mich dann auch nicht wirklich interessiert.
Lieber was einfaches liebe astrid.
Lieber was an ne das liegt astrophysik und dann ging es erstmal mit physik los das war.
Ok das ist ja auch nicht ohne.
Das war auch nicht ohne das ist nicht ohne und in der tat da habe ich aber gemerkt das ist das was mir was mir schon deutlich mehr liegt dass sie als die chemie,
und das habe ich dann zwei jahre studiert bis zum vor diplom und ja ich bin so.
Das interesse an der astronomie ist dann langsam wieder gekommen äh nach dem vor diplom.
Als es darum ging ja wo du wofür entscheidest du dich jetzt so machst du dein schwerpunkt in der physik,
und dann habe ich verschiedene seminare gehört in verschiedenen fach unter fachrichtungen der physik und dann bin ich plötzlich wieder auf die astrophysik gekommen was ich da seminare gehört habe habe ich dann gemerkt das ist ja total interessant und,
dass man dann sozusagen der zeitpunkt wo ich dann zur astronomie zurückgekommen bin.
Und ich hab da meine diplomarbeit gemacht und das war so der zeitpunkt wo es dann richtig losgeht wo man interesse wirklich groß war und ja seitdem will ich da in der astrophysik geblieben.
Und auch immer hier in tübingen.
Ne das war in kiel ich habe in der uni kiel studiert und auch promovieren michael,
und bin dann nach.
Nach bamberg gegangen zur sternwarte die gehört zur uni erlangen nürnberg da habe ich ein jahr gearbeitet.
Und äh dann hab ich die möglichkeit gehabt meine erste dauer stelle zu kriegen das war in der uni potsdam anfang der neunziger jahre und da war ich dann oberarzt system gewesen und dann,
etwa ein jahr nachdem ich dann nach potsdam gegangen bin habe ich dann den ruf nach tübingen gekommen bekommen und das ist jetzt ungefähr fünfundzwanzig jahre her so lange bin ich jetzt hier.
Okay also lange wird man sich ja auch als professor.
Genau.
Ja in dem institut vielleicht nochmal was zu sagen institut für astronomie und ich habe schon gesagt was ist denn hier so der.
Damit beschäftigt man sich denn hier so primär.
Ja also unser institut besteht aus aus vier abteilungen die jetzt unterschiedliche fachrichtungen astrophysik.
Sozusagen erforschen also wir haben einen kollegen der,
sich mehr mit excel planeten system beschäftigt aggression schreiben mir so auf theoretischer schiene,
und ähm dann haben wir einen kollegen der gravitationswellen macht relativ typische astrophysik also verschmelzende neuronen sterne das was jetzt gerade so.
Der hype ist ganz aktuell ist und dann jetzt speziell
auf meiner seite wir haben so zwei richtungen zwei abteilungen die eine abteilung ist die hoch energie astrophysik die beschäftigt sich mit
beobachtungen von mit rund teleskopen oder gamma,
und den bau von solchen teleskopen und dann schließlich meine abteilung,
die sich hauptsächlich mit der mit dem bau von ultraviolett teleskopen und ins also instrumenten für,
für weltraum teleskope beschäftigt und dann eben auch die entsprechende wissenschaft seite bearbeitet.
Das heißt hier wird nicht nur theoretisch gearbeitet sein wird auch ganz konkret an instrumenten gearbeitet und man arbeitet dann dementsprechend mit der ja einerseits mit der industrie aber natürlich vor allem auch so mit nasa isa etcetera zu.
Ja hauptsächlich deal erst hat unser haupt geldgeber sozusagen für die entwicklung dieser instrumente und ich denke mal da hat die uni tübingen schon alleinstellungsmerkmal in dem sinne dass wir,
ich glaube die einzige uni sind die jetzt im geschäft,
zum bau von instrument für weltraum teleskope ist.
Ja also auf astronomische seite und,
diese tradition die besteht schon relativ lange seit etwa dreißig fünfunddreißig jahren und äh wie gesagt das sind also im wesentlichen dann dinge was wir so beeilt arbeiten sind direktorin für,
ultra violett strahlung als auch strahlung das ist sozusagen unsere expertise im institut.
Ist schon fast ein bisschen ungewöhnlich wenn man da als universität in so einem hightech fällt sich behaupten kann aber auch noch über so lange zeit weil das ein unheimlich eher etwas ist was man tatsächlich eher in speziell geförderten instituten ddr.
Ja der max blank institut heimat.
Institute so in der serie ist natürlich einerseits natürlich super interessant wenn man dann hier sozusagen darüber nachdenkt als student.
Oder studenten hier zu starten was was hat das.
Das ist das fragen also welche anforderungen stellt das an einer universität so einen betrieb sozusagen zu ermöglichen wenn es nur so wenige schaffen.
Also das hauptproblem ist sozusagen man muss langen atem haben beziehungsweise auch über lange bezahlt,
versuchen finanziert zu werden weil diese weltraum projekte an dem man arbeitet demnächst sehr lange laufzeit haben also typischerweise mindestens zehn manchmal zwanzig jahre und das problem ist.
Das know-how von einer generation von studenten auf das land auf die nächste generation zu übertragen und wir haben da halt.
An den universitäten das spezielle problem dass wir praktisch keine dauer stellen haben wo wir diesen transfer von wissen über die zeit hinweg.
Machen können also wir haben halt die professoren und vielleicht den ein oder zwei assistenten stellen die dann längerfristig sagen wir mal auf sechs bis neun jahre,
befristet besetzt werden können aber eben nicht auf längere zeit und das ist unser hauptproblem also diese dieses nicht vorhanden sein von dauer stellen also dass wir ständig im personellen wechsel haben und versuchen müssen dieses know how was du über jahre angesammelt worden ist,
zu transferieren was auch um öfters mal nicht wirklich gelingt und
da haben wir halt äh als universität instituten ganz großem nachteil jetzt gegenüber max plank instituten die doch auch längerfristig planen planen können aber auf der anderen seite
sind wir sozusagen als uni institut die institution die sozusagen die erstmal die jungen leute anzieht und auf diese schiene draufsetzen kann also wir haben also viele unserer,
absolventen die jetzt ihre doktorarbeit hier fertig machen die gehen dann zu max blank instituten oder ddr instituten aber die kriegen halt hier bei uns unsere ausbildung,
und deshalb haben wir da schon eine gewisse da daseinsberechtigung in in unserer szene was eben auch zum beispiel auch die.
Max blank institute sehen also wir haben auch kollaboration mit max plank hinzu tun zum beispiel im garten und,
es ist also nicht so dass man jetzt schon in einem verdrängungswettbewerb drin ist sondern man sieht schon also dass die jungen leute,
hauptsächlich von den universitäten kommen und man muss die sozusagen an der universität,
anlernen um die dann in solche große institute zu kriegen.
Ja ich habe jetzt irgendwie komischerweise gerade so ein bild von seinem rock spiel wo alle so versuchen nach vorne zu stürmer muss halt die ganze zeit so die pille auch immer wieder nach hinten werfen um sozusagen alles im flo zu erhalten,
das stellt ja schon ganz andere bedingungen an so ein universität betrieb als man das vielleicht so normalerweise.
Ja ja ja wie gesagt dass man muss halt versuchen dann für diesen langen abend zu haben und.
Aber auch eine ganz andere teamfähigkeit eigentlich zu entwickeln ne weil das eben nicht alles so institutionalisierte ist weil man weiß wenn man das jetzt nicht innerhalb kürzester zeit dann immer wieder alle zwei drei jahre durch den ganzen studenten,
studentin kader durch bekommt dass dann eben das wissen einfach verloren geht.
Also eines der hauptprobleme ist ja wenn man in solchen weltraum projekten drin ist ist man ist eng an diese zeit,
pläne sozusagen man muss sich an diese zeitpläne halten was jetzt die kollaboration auch mit der industrie zum beispiel angeht,
und wenn es da mal 'ne verzögerung gibt dadurch dass irgendwie ein doktoranden weggeht oder sowas dann genau hat man dann ziemlich schnell erhebliche probleme.
Aber auf der anderen seite lernen auch die jungen leute schon von der pike auf wenn sie dann mit ihrer doktorarbeit anfangen
sich an solche engen zeitpläne zu halten die können nicht jetzt irgendwie ihre doktorarbeit von drei vier fünf auf zehn jahre verlängern sondern die meisten und auf die allermeisten kriegen also ihre doktorarbeit spätestens nach drei oder vier jahren fertig,
also da steht von anfang an ziemlich klar fest wie so eine doktorarbeit strukturiert.
Auch super wenn man jetzt nicht nur so rein theoretisch an irgendwelchen projekten,
sondern ganz konkret an irgendwas,
arbeitet was dann vielleicht zehn zwanzig jahre wenn so da eigene karriereweg sich schon weiterentwickelt hat das vielleicht überhaupt erst zum tragen guckt.
Genau ja also diese mitarbeitern weltraum projekten hat natürlich so seine eigene eigene sache eigenen appeal aber das hauptproblem ist auch.
Dass die,
die laufzeit dieser projekte solange es das heißt wenn ich jetzt einen doktoranden habe der jetzt an bestimmte hardware arbeitet dann wissen wir dass diese hardware vielleicht den c erst in zehn oder fünfzehn jahre jahren ins weltall fliegt,
und auf der anderen seite gibt es eben oder sollte es auch projekte geben die 'ne kürzere laufzeit haben also wir sind zum beispiel großen projekten in großen projekten involviert wie diese art tina mission die ersten fünfzehn oder zwanzig jahren starten wird,
es wäre viel wichtiger,
oder es ist viel wichtiger dass es auch kleinere projekte gibt wo studenten die jetzt an hardware entwicklung arbeiten auch die aussicht haben das vielleicht in den nächsten drei oder vier jahren das was sie da hergestellt haben dann auch geflogen wird und und solche solche
für solche projekte ist leider immer weniger geld da weil die großen agenturen wie das der auf die esa.
Hauptsächlich geld reinstecken in diese langfristigen großprojekte die irgendwie lang die lange laufzeiten haben und nicht in diese kurzzeitige projekte also was jetzt zum beispiel der welt raumfahrt ja immer weiter,
an fahrt aufnimmt sind diese cup satz also diese kleinen satelliten.
Wo man viele der komponenten sozusagen oft der chef kaufen kann und für diese satelliten verwenden kann um man also eine sehr viel kürzere,
vorbereitungszeit platt bis ein solches experiment fliegt und ich finde da müsste eigentlich viel mehr gemacht werden also viel mehr geld investiert werden auch zum beispiel von von der seite.
Weil es eben ganz wichtig ist studenten auszubildende also von der pike auf lernen wie man ein solches projekte designt entwickelt und am ende auch fliegt.
Da hatte ich hier kleiner hinweis in raum zeit neunundfünfzig schönes gespräch mit klaus pries von der theo berlin die sich ja sehr oft die genau diese,
konzentrieren da kamen ähnliche argumente na gut aber so hast du jeder so seine spezialität und im bereich weltraum teleskope mitreden zu können das ist ja was.
Wann war denn bei ihnen so der erste die erste begegnung mit den gruppen war das dann schon habe oder das schon.
Ne das war das fing schon vorher an also so meine,
sagen wir mal die haupt richtung in meiner wissenschaftlichen tätigkeit,
ist sterne entwicklung oder endphase der sterne entwicklung,
und wir interessieren uns hauptsächlich für heiße sterne heiße weise zwerge neu dronen stern und sowas die halt hauptsächlich,
die elektromagnetischen energie die sie ab strahlen im ufo der rückenbereich ab strahlen das heißt wenn man sowas beobachten will dann ist man immer auf weltraum teleskope angewiesen.
Und es gab vor.
Weil man das auch am boden.
Weil man es am boden nicht sehen kann weil die erdatmosphäre das diese strahlung absolviert ja und es gab natürlich schon vorhabe weltraum teleskope und auch auf der seite,
der ultraviolett seite wo wir besonders daran interessiert es gab es auch halt schon vorgänger projekte und zu der zeit als ich sozusagen als student ins geschäft gekommen bin,
ein projekt das damals lief war der international ultra explorer gewesen dass man eine amerikanische europäische zusammenarbeit das war ja das kann man so sagen das waren vorläufer von,
habe gewesen allerdings ein relativ kleines teleskopen im spiegel durchmesser ich glaube nicht mehr als vierzig oder fünfzig zentimeter was eben hochauflösend spektrums kopie im ultraviolett spektral bereich,
gemacht hat und zu der zeit als ich da ins geschäft gekommen.
War gab es diese mission und habe kam dann erst.
Neunzehnhundertneunzig mit dem staat
und das war jetzt natürlich eine ganz große nummer gewesen dass man dass man jetzt also mit diesem großen teleskop passt also spiegel durchmesser zehnmal größer war im objekt der beobachten konnte die wir vorher mit den anderen weltraum teleskopen nicht beobachten kann.
Das ist international ultra explorer eu jeder hat man auch wieder nicht so richtig den griff für,
namen die einen schnell von der zunge gehen ne,
achtundsiebzig gestartet kann man fast sagen dass in der zeit eigentlich über den siebziger jahren überhaupt.
In der raumfahrt überhaupt die tradition werden statt von jetzt wollen wir mal zum mond und,
bei einem erste nation sein ja dieses space was ich da insbesondere amerikaner und die russen geleistet haben dann könnt ihr das ja so ein bisschen abhängen,
das auf einmal so alles viel zu teuer war soeben konnte nichts teuer genug sein und jetzt wo die bremse angezogen aber das bedeutet ja auch das eigentlich die wissenschaft mehr in den fokus,
dass man jetzt gesagt hat ok jetzt sind wir schon mal soweit nutzen wir das doch jetzt mal auch mal für ein paar sachen wo wo es jetzt nicht darum geht einfach mal einen coolen auto auf mund rum zu düsen so toll das auch ist so ne aber man hat ja noch mehr rausholen können,
und auch so diese nummer das ja am anfang man eigentlich glaube ich auch raumfahrt anders gesehen haben es wurde erstmal nur piloten,
hoch geschickt weil man dachte so das wäre jetzt so eine qualifikation,
aber kaum hat man mal geologisch auf mond kam auf einmal die interessanten steine zurück das war ja auch so ein bisschen so 'ne so 'ne reflexion sondern so 'ne so 'ne feststellung so vielleicht ist er auch noch mehr zu holen,
ich sehe so diesen staat der der teleskope so ein bisschen in diesem trend.
Ja genau das war so in den mitte der mitte ende der siebziger jahre als das da richtig losgehen.
Okay das heißt dieser explorer siebenundfünfzig wäre auch heißt war jetzt schon mal.
Gebaut worden um einfach diesen frequenz bereich des elektromagnetischen spektrums zu sehen die die atmosphäre eben nicht oder nicht durch lässt also aussieht.
Sonderlich scharf war der blick wahrscheinlich noch nicht aber man sah überhaupt schon mal was.
Erstmal darum sozusagen überhaupt technik also spiegel bauen hoch schießen betreiben etcetera muss man auch erst mal gemacht haben.
Ja genau.
War damit möglich und was hat das ausgelöst.
Ja wenn man also im ultraviolett bereich astronomische beobachtungen machen will dann braucht man halt spezielle spiegel beschichtung spezielle detektor toren und das wald,
etwas was man erstmal entwickeln musste und was dann weltraum tauglich sein musste und die grundlage dafür sind halt dann in den siebziger jahren,
gelegt worden.
Aber man wusste auch okay das hat jetzt,
im wesentlichen funktioniert aber damit so richtig spaß macht brauchen wir was was richtig.
Na ja also dieser international dieses dieser eu satellit den ich gerade erwähnte das war eben kein satt liter jetzt bilder gemacht hat sondern wirklich nur spektrum,
ich soll den nicht nur sagen sondern spektrums kopie gemacht hat und deshalb hat das keine schaffen auch immer keine scharfen bilder gemacht aber für ich sag mal für die astrophysik ist,
neben dem bilder machen also dem coaching wie wir sagen die spektrums kopie mindestens genauso wichtig wahrscheinlich sogar wichtiger sind dann sage ich jetzt mal von meiner warte.
Und.
Um die zusammensetzung von.
Die chemische zusammensetzung also weil die letztendlich fast alle informationen die wir von eltern kriegen so in den spektrum drin liegt ne die man irgendwie verstehen,
und insofern war dieser eu schon was neues gewesen man man konnte also schon erstmal sich anschauen wie,
sterne oder auch galaxien im ultra spektral bereich überhaupt aussehen das musste man also gar nicht ne und basierend darauf dieser satz hat jetzt auch zwanzig jahre oder so vorhaben gelebt
hatte man dann natürlich schon den wunsch jetzt mal objekte anzuschauen die also relativ weit entfernt sind und deshalb finstere sind dunkler sind die man halt mit diesem bio satelliten dann nicht beobachten konnte und da er,
kam der wunsch hervor jetzt brauchen wir wirklich dann diesen großen dieses große teleskop um die wissenschaftler weitertreiben zu können,
und die sagen wir mal wenn man mal so in die geschichte reinschaut so die geschichte des handel teleskop es geht ja auch schon zurück in die,
was ich vierzig oder fünfziger jahre als dann erste ideen jetzt auf amerikanischer seite aufgaben so eine astronomische ist ohne observatorium ins all zu schicken.
Und also da ist das handy teleskop dann in den neunziger jahren kaum das hatte sehr viel verspätung gehabt also der ursprünglich staat war ja,
ich weiß auch nicht fünf oder zehn jahre vorher geplant da gab's jetzt verschiedene schwierigkeiten und das war so dann genau die richtige zeit sozusagen für die gastronomie,
was denn das teleskop ins all geschossen geworden geschossen wurde.
Ja bei den gruppen ist werden wir später noch sehen sind solche verzögerung,
geradezu eingebaut glaube ich prinzip bedingt weil sie eben auch einfach super komplexe systeme sind,
kommen wir nochmal auf habe also nachdem er sozusagen diese ersten erkenntnisse hatte und jetzt so ein bisschen die lust auf mehr war ist ja immer so eine wichtige phase bei so einem projekt so am anfang überhaupt erstmal ziele zu setzen also man muss ja irgendwie erstmal wissen so okay was,
was meinen wir letztlich technisch auch lösen zu können was was für fragen ja gut die fragen.
Die man später beantworten kann kann man meistens eh nicht so direkt vorhersehen aber sozusagen rein technisch will man ja erstmal so seine skills verbessern an den stellen wo man denkt erst am meisten zu holen ist was war so der schwerpunkt babel.
Ja na ja aber jetzt mal von den technischen herausforderungen abgesehen
um jetzt vom geldgeber oder erstmal den geldgeber zu überzeugen dass man jetzt so ein projekt lostreten kann also was so in der größenordnung von fast einer milliarde mehr als eine milliarde dollar und euros ist muss man natürlich schon sagen warum man so ein teleskopie,
haben will also dass was wir jetzt als case betrachten also man muss schon sagen welche rätsel,
welche astronomischen rätsel wollen wir eigentlich mit einem solchen teleskop,
lösen und wenn man da keine gute begründung hat dann kriegt man dafür auch auch kein geld und das was damals halt im vordergrund stand als das handel teleskop geplant worden ist der der wichtigste science war damals eben,
gewesen die ausdehnung rate des universums also die aussehens geschwindigkeit wie alt ist das universum eigentlich und das war so eines der.
Aufgaben oder auf hochdeutsch die kitas ki-projekte eines der keeper,
das mit dem beobachtung des teleskop s.
Gelöst werden sollte so und diese diese technischen singen dinge ja dass man muss natürlich zeigen dass man in der lage ist,
diese technische probleme die damit verbunden sind auch zu lösen,
aber die stehen erstmal nicht im vordergrund also wenn man wie gesagt den geldgeber überzeugen will dann muss man sagen welche rätsel sozusagen die wir haben wollen wir eigentlich damit angehen.
Was würde denn so ausgepackt aus dem sack der versprechungen.
Sagt der versprechung aus war zum beispiel eben auch die das wichtigste beim die gabel konstante gewesen dass dass man bestimmen wollte wie,
wie groß ist die ausdehnung geschwindigkeit des universums also zu der zeit dass das gut gestartet worden ist
ähm war die der werte habe konstanten sehr ungenau bekannt irgendwo zwischen fünfzig und hundert kilometer pro sekunde.
Hier mal rein fragen was ist die konstante.
Okay gut ich habe konstante gibt letztendlich an wie alt das universum ist also wir wissen das universum expandiert seitdem ur knall und man möchte gerne wissen wann diese uhr knallt stattgefunden hat und,
die habe konstante misst sozusagen die ausdehnung geschwindigkeit des universums und wenn man da so die geschwindigkeit hat.
Steckt denn diese konstante drin in welcher formel.
Ja die steckt also na ja das ist halt einfach nur,
oder sagen wir mal wenn man jetzt die das universum die expansion des universums betrachtet als eine sozusagen als eine explosion die sie immer weiter ausdehnt,
dann beobachtet man jetzt sozusagen die die teile die bei der explosion auseinander fliegen und will jetzt zurück rechnen wann diese explosion an diese expansion angefangen hat.
Und die halbe konstante gibt sozusagen an mit welcher geschwindigkeit die galaxien voneinander wegfliegen und diese geschwindigkeit also im wesentlichen wenn man diese geschwindigkeit messen.
Aber dann geht man davon aus dass diese geschwindigkeit konstant ist.
Da genau richtig das ist erstmal in erster ernährung wenn ich das so beschreibe das geht diese simple betrachtung geht erst mal davon aus dass diese geschwindigkeit konstant ist was er so heißt,
man nimmt an dass die gravitation diese expansion geschwindigkeit nicht besonders abgebremst oder man kann natürlich jetzt versuchen diese zweite ordnung effekte,
noch zu bestimmen wie also jetzt die ab bremsung dann jetzt noch weiter reinspielt also genau genommen die die habe konstante gibt nicht ganz genau das alter des universums an sondern das ist eine von zwei,
physikalischen größen die man messen muss einmal eben die die aus den geschwindigkeit und die,
den abbremsen parameter der also jetzt abgibt angibt,
wie die expansion des universums abgebremst wird durch die gravitation oder wie wir eben seit neuem seit einiger zeit,
wie die expansion des universums weiter beschleunigt wird und diese zwei parameter die braucht man,
um das alter des universums zu bestimmen.
Das ist ja auch so eine der bahnbrechenden erkenntnisse der wissenschaft so der letzten zehn zwanzig jahre,
eben genau diese feststellung.
Womit wir es eigentlich gerade zu tun haben mit unserem universum in bezug darauf wie es sich so verhält weil am anfang war das ja unklar die uhr knallt theorie gibt's schon etwas länger ist irgendwie durch viele beobachtungen auch,
belegt und immer wieder bestätigt worden soweit ich das verstehe aber es war jetzt vollkommen unklar,
was man jetzt für eine schlussfolgerung ausziehen sollte man sah halt etwas was was ja expandiert ich weiß gar nicht ob explosionen so die die richtige begriff dafür ist weil es ja sozusagen der raum selber ist der sich sozusagen aus weitet.
Und am anfang gab es ja schon so die idee naja okay wenn ihr jetzt so viel zeug drin ist was so viel gravitation hat was irgendwie ganze galaxien kreisen lässt so vielleicht,
nimmt ja sozusagen diese beschleunigen irgendwie wieder ab und das wird alles durch gravitation wieder so einen ursprungspunkt geführt und so die idee dass man sozusagen immer mal wieder nur knall hat alle paar jahre,
und dann geht es wieder von vorne los aber das scheint ja durch die beobachtung später widerlegt worden zu sein.
Genau also bevor man jetzt durch diese neuen beobachtung gefunden hat dass das universum beschleunigt expandiert sah halt
die waren halt die messergebnisse so aus dass das universum gerade eine solche ausgabe ausdehnen geschwindigkeit hat dass man von dem beobachtungen damals nicht recht entscheiden konnte,
geht diese ausdehnung unendlich weit in die zukunft weiter oder
zieht sich das universum wieder zusammen aufgrund der gravitation des materie inhalt des universums und nach
dem parameter die man damals kante für die konstante und den abbremsen den abbremsen parameter erwarten bis damals nicht klar haben wir eine ewige expansion oder eben die das zyklische universum was sie gerade angesprochen haben.
Beobachten beobachtung beruht denn die ersten annahmen überhaupt wenn man jetzt noch kein weltraum teleskop hatte um genauer nachzuschauen.
Ja also die wesentlichen beobachtungen die man gemacht hat waren halt die die ideen die man in weit entfernten galaxien,
beobachtet hat wo man eben durch die beobachtung der zivilen durch die,
durch die position periode sind variable sterne auf die leucht kräfte dieser sterne geschlossen hat und damit eben durch die abstände zu den galaxien,
bestimmen konnte so und das ist das ganz ganz große problem abstände halt im weltall zu vermessen und durch die beobachtung des zufrieden ist es halt.
Im prinzip möglich und das andere was man eben braucht ist die die geschwindigkeit mit der
die galaxien von uns wegfliegen oder wie sie halt richtig sagen äh der raum zwischen den galaxien dehnt sich aus aber man kann halt durch die rot verschiebung der galaxien diese ausdehnung geschwindigkeit messen und erst erstmal erst wenn man die
die geschwindigkeit und die entfernung zusammen nimmt kann man eben jetzt.
Bestimmen mit welcher expansion des universum expandiert,
also es waren im wesentlichen die c gewesen die wir.
Die leute als standard kerzen hergenommen haben und auf der diese beobachtung der expansion des universums beruhen also seit tabelle damals,
waren das so die erkenntnisse gewesen seid in zwanziger jahren die beruhen im wesentlichen auf der beobachtung von c frieden und das ist eben angetreten mit dem ziel,
diese zertifikaten in noch weit entfernt und galaxien zu finden und damit eben die expansion geschwindigkeit noch genauer zu vermessen.
Was man an dieser stelle mal sagen sollten ist natürlich die konzerte heißt deshalb vor allem hab ich konstante weil sie von habe ursprünglich mal ausgedacht wurde,
weil sie auch der namensgeber dieses vertrauen teleskop geworden weil er sich eben einfach generell mit,
der ausdehnung der des universums beschäftigt also neben vielen anderen dingen die sicherlich auch noch gemacht hat aber das so ein bisschen das primäre vermächtnis das sei an dieser stelle noch kurz,
erwähnt,
okay also das war sozusagen um mal wieder zurückzukommen auf das ursprüngliche versprechen also was man jetzt eigentlich vorhat wir brauchen jetzt mal den weltraum teleskop weil wir haben zwar annahmen und wir haben irgendwie so beobachtungen alles irgendwie alle nicht genau genug oder wir wissen nicht ob sie genau genossen,
um wirklich daraus eine schlussfolgerung zu machen wie es sich denn sozusagen mit dem universum wirklich verhält natürlich auch so ein so ein versprechen was glaube ich so in der politik jetzt erstmal nicht so auf totale begeisterung stößt so nach dem motto,
letzte mal seid ihr noch mit dem auto irgendwie über mond gefahren das klang irgendwie besser.
Na ja aber da.
Wissenschaftler bringt das natürlich total aus dem häuschen gelangten.
Ja klar aber ich meine da springen sie natürlich ein allgemeines problem an wie kann man jetzt erst oder wie kann man,
den geldgeber die politiker davon überzeugen dass astronomie eine wichtige sache ist ja ich mein vor diesem problem stehen wir natürlich laufend und deshalb versuchen wir halt die beobachtung,
oder sagen wir mal die öffentlichkeit zu begeistern von oder von unserer besten begeisterung anzustecken dass wir eben schon glauben dass es wichtig ist für uns menschen,
so die einsicht zu haben in welcher art universum leben wir eigentlich noch na klar ist das jetzt eine erkenntnis die jetzt kein geld bringt und äh aber ich finde.
Weiß ich nicht das finde ich immer so ein bisschen eine falsche wahrnehmung mal sagst du ja wen interessiert schon die expansion des universums darf,
kriege ich ja nichts mit das ding ist ja nur in dem moment wo man sowas für dich genau untersucht dann
kann halt irgendwann irgendwann kommen immer wieder an diesen punkt wo man bestimmte theorien auch komplett ausschließen kann was dann sozusagen
weitere logik spielchen zulässt beim verfolgen anderer theorien und irgendwann kommt mal dann wieder wenn man das mal sieht dann im zahn was man dann immer wieder nochmal genauer wonach gesucht werden
muss und dann wird 's ja auch gefunden und die auswirkungen davon sind zwar sehr langfristig aber auch extrem fundamental,
überhaupt erstmal bestimmte grundlegende dinge und erkenntnisse hat um neue materialien herzustellen oder eben ganz.
Ja dieser ja dieser weg kann aber eben sehr lang sein und das ist auch sehr gut deshalb ist es schwierig ja.
Aber er ist ja da nun in gewisser hinsicht auch messbar na gut auf jeden fall habe wurde dann beschlossen schauen wir doch mal was was so drin ist in dem apparat.
Ja
Also was was muss man denn jetzt was sollte jetzt wirklich beobachtet werden und wie beobachtet man sowas.
Ja was ist drin im apparat des wichtigste natürlich ist ja der teleskop spiegel und am,
man hatte damals natürlich schon in den wunsch garten relativ großes teleskop ins all zu schießen und das ging damals halt nur weil man dann schließlich die shuttle flotte zur verfügung hatte die weltraum fern um dieses teleskop auch zu starten
und der nächste wunsch den man hatte ist dass man eben auch die möglichkeit haben wollte dieses teleskop zu warten das heißt dass man da alle paar jahre dann,
ein astronauten team hinschickt um zum beispiel neue instrumente einzusetzen das war so eine der sachen gewesen die man auf jeden fall haben wollte,
und das ging damals halt nur dadurch dass die amerikaner ihre weltraum für ihre zur verfügung hatten,
und wir wissen ja nachdem dieses programm dann angemeldet worden ist dieses shuttle programm das seitdem eben auch das teleskop sozusagen alleine rum fliegt und nicht mehr gewartet werden kann man zum glück alles diese lange periode bisher ganz gut überlebt,
ja also es ist ein großer spiegel der da drin ist und.
Neben dem spiegel natürlich wichtig sind die instrumente die das licht dass dieser spiegel dann einfängt dann eben auch empfängt also die empfänger und dann eben die spektrum graphen beziehungsweise die kameras die dann.
Mehr oder weniger scharfe bilder von den kosmetischen objekten macht also
sagen wir mal so einen teleskop spiegel ist relativ die relativ einfachste komponente schwierig genug weil wie man will
weiß aber sehr viel wichtiger oder mindestens genauso wichtig sind eben die wichtig sind eben die instrumente die da hinten dran sind also in der pokal ebene,
um dieses licht wirklich dann analysieren zu können,
und das habe ich das teleskop hatte von anfang an mehrere instrumente an bord eben solche.
In kameras wie wir sagen also solche kameras die bilder machen und eben auch spektrum hafen.
Und äh diese instrumente sind dann im laufe der zeit ähm ausgetauscht,
worden und.
Vielleicht erstmal mit dem was was geplant war,
was mich mal interessieren würde man man will ja sozusagen das licht was man einfängt auf unterschiedliche art und weisen untersuchen und deswegen hat man unterschiedliche instrumente ist los in fünf verschiedenen.
Fünf jahren.
Wie ist denn das technisch realisiert dass das licht was er eingefangen wird durch den,
an fünf verschiedenen orten ausgewertet werden.
Na ja im prinzip landet dieses licht ja in in der brennen ebene des tellers,
und diese brenne ebene ist also zwei dimensionale ebene wo man also an verschiedenen positionen der brennen ebene dann,
die verschiedene kameras die verschiedenen instrumente runterbringen kann ja das heißt man guckt sich ein bestimmtes objekt an und schwenkt dann das teleskop ein bisschen,
so in die richtung so in eine bestimmte richtung sodass also das licht in der brennen ebene in ein bestimmtes instrument reinfällt.
Verstehe also man wackelt sozusagen ein bisschen mit dem teleskop hin und her das heißt man hat nicht so einen spiegel wo das nochmal aufgeteilt wird weil das würde er dann wiederum liegt.
Genau das das frisst wieder licht auf und das war vorbei vermeidet man sowas man kann also üblicherweise immer nur ein instrument leichter,
also bei den kameras und spektrum gramm ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich man kann man kann zum beispiel eine kamera und ein spektakel hafen gleichzeitig benutzen auch man könnte zum beispiel nicht,
zwei spektrum grafen gleichzeitig benutzen weil die haben so einen engen eingang spalt und da kann man das nicht nur in ein oder den anderen spektrum graphen hineinbringen.
Das heißt ja relativ große spiegel wie groß ist ja zweieinhalb meter.
Zwei komma zwei sechs oder zwei komma sieben ja.
Also vergleichsweise großer spiegel muss auch bedenken spiegel können wir ja alle fallen gerne runter und dann sind sie kaputt so das darf natürlich nicht passieren,
was man sich immer wieder klar machen muss ist dass die diese geräte ja beim start einen enormen vibration ausgesetzt ist aber zu diese raketen start das heißt es muss irgendwie gleichzeitig stabil aber eben auch sehr filigran,
gebaut werden das ist ja dann auch gelungen eben an bord eines shuttle,
irgendwie auch jetzt schon langsam so eine so eine zeit ist die man sich irgendwie gar nicht mehr vorstellen kann jetzt haben wir halt nur den normalen raketen betrieb.
Aber damals war er so dieser traum von der universellen,
stationen also nicht im all sein im juni universelle versorgung des erdnahen orbit wurde auf einmal ganz real.
Und lange zeit hat man glaube ich diesen traum geträumt dass man halt einfach gemerkt hat,
zu teuer zu ineffizient und dann leider eben auch durch die viele katastrophen eben auch in seiner komplexität einfach zu wenig beherrscht bar um hier wirklich in sicheren bezahlbaren betrieb herzustellen so dass es dann wieder eingestellt werden musste aber für habe,
war das ja im prinzip die ideale zeit weil man eben wirklich auch mal die zeit hatte die gelegenheit hatte nicht nur was extrem komplexes ins all zu kriegen sondern sich dabei auch noch fehler zu erlauben weil es ist ja.
Nicht alles gut gelaufen was ist denn falsch gelaufen als habe gestartet ist,
war das ding ja so ein bisschen blind auf dem einen auge.
Auf auf dem alten.
Dem einzigen auge.
Ja das war natürlich damals die große katastrophe gewesen dass man festgestellt hat.
Dass das teleskop keine scharfen bilder machen konnte das heißt es hat eine weile gedauert bis man dann erkannt hat dass der viele der spiegel falsch geschliffen war.
Und ja und man hat sich dann eine weile überlegt wie kann man das sozusagen reparieren bis man darauf.
Warum waren denn falsch.
Ja das war ja das war halt ein fehler im herstellungsprozess gewesen bei der firma die diesen spiegel hergestellt hat,
die haben da einen bestimmten fehler gemacht es geht darum diesen spiegel zu schleifen
und die haben halt operator benutzt wo man diesen diesen,
schleift mechanismus etwas falsch gemacht hat also man hat da irgendwelche abstands halte die man braucht um,
die,
die genaue form des spiegel zu vermessen dieser abstand halten hatte halt irgendwie eine differenz zu dem wasser haben sollte von eins zu zwei millimeter sodass der spiegel dann etwas falsch geschliffen war es war sehr wenig außerdem ausgereicht.
Um unscharfe bilder zu erzeugen also dass man viele,
bei dem spiegel hersteller gewesen und naja die die nase hat halt dann auch ziemlich ärger bekommen und vielleicht auch zu recht,
weil man dieses auf dem boden nie wirklich ausprobiert hat als dass man dieses ganze spiegel system.
Auf dem boden nicht wirklich vermessen und zu gucken und macht es denn scharf wurde unscharfe bilder man was ich so sicher gewesen man hat jetzt so ein tolles teleskop gebaut,
das muss einfach funktionieren,
und man hat diese test positiv prozedur nicht gemacht weil das wieder ein paar millionen dollar oder sowas gekostet hätte und das war damals ein großer gefühl großer fehler gewesen.
Ja also das waren ziemlich ziemlich simpler fehler der gemacht worden ist bei der.
Also eigentlich gab's ja zwei fehler ne also das ist das eine war okay da geht mal was schief aber so ist das halt nochmal bei technik es geht halt was schief aber was eigentlich gefehlt hat war das richtige system um diesen fehler rechtzeitig.
Genau die qualitätskontrolle die war da war das das hat nicht funktioniert weil es hat die nase halt nicht gemacht.
Also neunzehnhundertneunzig ist habe gestartet worden eben mit einem space shuttle ausgesetzt worden ist richtig schön mit dem kran raus gehoben und so tolle bilder.
Das war glaube ich auch die mission eines,
bis die bis dahin den höchsten arbeit überhaupt.
Ja kann sein ja.
Kilometer das hat alles wunderbar funktioniert aber dann nimmt man das ding im betrieb und stellt fest so okay unscharf.
Und dann wurde ja dann quasi wie das eben so ist ne damit man so 'ne working group aufsetzen und dann jetzt gucken wir mal ganz genau was sie eigentlich schief gegangen ist und dann wurde glaube ich in windeseile wurde glaube ich erstmal festgestellt.
Wir können das jetzt nicht austauschen also man kann sich neuen spiegel machen und den weil wir einfach zu aufwendig zu teuer zu schwierig zu kompliziert gewesen aber man kann den ding die brille verpassen.
Genau.
Und dann wurde quasi so eine brille gebaut.
Richtig also man hat diese also eine korrektur optik in den strahlen gang hinein gesetzt um diesen fehler sozusagen wieder heraus zu korrigieren.
Und diese diese optik die hat man dann ich glaube etwa drei jahre zwei oder drei jahre später.
Mit einer anderen schatten mission ins all gebracht und die astronauten haben sozusagen dem teleskop diese brille dann verpasst.
Danach wird beim sozusagen alles gut gewesen.
Und dann hat man das ding eingeschaltet und getestet und festgestellt hoppala jetzt geht's los das heißt mit drei jahren verzögerung nachdem er vorher natürlich schon viele jahre verzögerung hatte habe eigentlich überhaupt das erste mal das gesehen was man sehen wollte.
So teils teils ist also nicht so dass das kabel teleskop nicht wissenschaftlich produktiv war in den ersten drei jahren also wovon.
Diese optische fehler oder was diese optische fehler jetzt nicht nicht so wahnsinnig beeinflusst hat war die spektrums kopie gewesen,
ähm natürlich was was wirklich große auswirkungen hatte war eben auf die den modus also wenn man jetzt bilder von fernen galaxien aufnahmen die waren alle unscharf gewesen aber.
Für die spektrums kopierst eigentlich mehr die richtung relevant.
Genau man braucht man genau man braucht also nicht die räumliche auflösung für die spektrums kopie und von daher,
alles gut in den ersten jahren auf spektrum seite schon ziemlich das erreichen,
können was äh was man so geplant hat also ist es war nicht umsonst diese ersten zwei drei jahre.
Aber es war auch nicht umsonst das zu fixen weil.
Dann.
Die bilder glaube ich sogar besser als man das sich oft hat.
Als das ursprünglich ja das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen ob du dich besser waren als als ursprünglich geplant war aber zumindest genauso gut.
Was wo jetzt ist es ja so mit solchen,
teleskopen mit allen satelliten aber bei teleskopen ist es ja immer noch mal besonders dramatisch,
es kann ja im prinzip überall hingucken wird das richtig sehe der,
grenzbereich also das elektromagnetischen spektrum was jetzt mit dir mit hagel aufgelöst werden kann zieht sich,
quasi voll durch den sichtbaren bereich aber eben auch in den infrarot bereich und in ultraviolett bereich also hat sozusagen so.
Genau.
Mensch das visuelle licht plus plus.
Links und rechts ein bisschen wasser ja ja.
Warum wurde genau dieser bereich jetzt gewählt weil es erstmal weil immer ging so im vordergrund stand,
oder weil da jetzt ein bisschen was großer bedarf war man hätte es ja auch vielleicht noch höher treiben können oder wo sind da die grenzen bei dem,
konzept.
Ja also da gibt es technische grenzen bei diesem konzept also der das erste war natürlich man wollten
teleskop haben was im optischen spektral bereich arbeitet und da muss man jetzt gucken wie viel von den angrenzenden spektral bereichen kriegt man mit einer solchen technik dann auch noch hin und
stellt sich immer raus ja man kann so ein bisschen ins ultraviolett reinschauen aber nicht zu noch kürzeren wellenlänge also noch hören ton energien.
Der limitierenden faktor.
Der limitierte faktor ist zum beispiel die beschichtung des haupt spiegels oder die beschichtung von instrumenten die sind also dann nicht mehr empfindlich um sommer der spiegel reflexion des spiegels ist nicht in der lage,
licht oder sagen die belegung des spiegels ist nicht in der lage licht zu reflektieren,
was kürzere wellenlänge hat als der klassische uvp bereich also es kann zum beispiel keine ton einfangen,
na das heißt also wenn man zu hohen energien gehen will braucht man andere teleskope,
andere beschichtungen andere instrumente auch andere diktatoren die also v direktorin oder optische direktorin können kein ranking nicht sehen
zu sagen und genauso verhält es sich dann auf der info roten seite also wenn man dann ins ins fernsehen,
gut gehen will braucht man auch,
andere spiegel beschichtung und vor anderen vor allem auch andere direktorinnen,
das heißt also man hat jetzt nicht die allzu groß auswahl wenn man von optischen spektral bereich rausgeht bleibt eigentlich nur noch das uv und das nahe in frau,
aus technischen gründen.
Ja aber wenn man das jetzt mit dem menschlichen auges vergleich hat man im prinzip so ein super auge also die also manche tiere was gibt's eigentlich tiere die so ein ähnlichen ähnlicher auflösung haben.
Im infrarot.
Ja es gibt also tiere mehr bis ein bisschen weiter ins um frau reingehen oder ein bisschen weiter ins infrarot aber eben auch nicht viel mehr weil ja oder auch nicht viel weiter raus weil ihm die erdatmosphäre kein kein sonnenlicht,
durch lässt und das von der biologischen seite von der evolution her nicht interessant.
Lösung.
Ok jetzt worauf ich hinaus wollte ist eigentlich jetzt hat man diese ganzen möglichkeiten.
Wer darf denn daran.
Jetzt starten sie nicht jeder genau jetzt standen sie ja dann wahrscheinlich alle da vielleicht nochmal kurz welche rolle hatten dann hier quasi die uni konkret bei bei habel gespielt null,
aber sie waren schon in irgendeiner form beteiligt an dem projekt.
Also jetzt was die hardware seite angeht wenn wir überhaupt nicht,
über die wissenschaft mit genau die wissenschaftliche auswertung ja das geht dann dann so in die frage wer kommt jetzt an die beobachtung zeit ran und also das prozedere sieht einfach so aus,
dass man einmal pro jahr zu einer bestimmten deadline halt anträge stellen kann beobachtung anträge stellen kann,
und dann werden diese anträge gesammelt und ein ein gremium weitergegeben was halt dann jetzt diese,
anträge sich anschaut und ein ranking macht was ist das beste was ist das schlechteste und da wird sich halt angeschaut was jetzt jetzt von der wissenschaft seite am interessantesten was man da mit dem teleskope machen kann und dann wird halt tür geguckt was kann man,
beobachten in der zur verfügung stehenden zeit und es stellt sich immer raus,
dass mehr beobachtung beantragt wird als wirklich zur verfügung steht und dann wird halt in diesem ranking dann irgendwo mal abgeschnitten,
und es stellt sich raus dass du der sogenannte überprüfung faktor für das teleskop irgendwo zwischen sieben und zehn liegt das heißt die anzahl oder die beobachtung das zeigt die beantragt.
Ist sie mal höher sozusagen der tag vierundzwanzig stunden zur verfügung hat und das heißt die konkurrenz ist extrem stark man muss also einen guten antrag schreiben und äh sozusagen das gutachter gremium überzeugen
dass man da eine wissenschaft machen will die wichtig wichtiger ist als das was ein konkurrent machen will.
Ja wird ja immer nur die qualität dieses antrages gemacht oder hat man erstmal gesagt okay unser ziel ist jetzt hier konstant herauszufinden jetzt wählen wir erstmal nur beobachtung
raus die in irgendeiner form auch versuchen da entsprechende ergebnisse zu erzielen.
Ja es gab natürlich von anfang an diese sogenannten ki-projekte und die bestimmung der havel konstante war eines davon wo es halt,
garantierte beobachtung zeit gehabt da hat man sie vorher genau sich ausgelegt welche galaxien mit welchem frieden,
oder welche galaxien guck mich mal an um zu suchen aber dann ein großer teil der beobachtung zeit war dann sozusagen frei für jeden astronom der halt einen antrag stellen konnte und in der zwischenzeit ist so,
das praktisch alle beobachtung zwei ton habe in diesem freien verfahren,
vergeben wird das heißt jeder astronom aus jedem land ich glaube china ist die einzige ausnahme kann beobachtung anträge stellen und es wird wirklich nur nach der wissenschaft,
bewertet und nicht aus welchem gastronom aus welchem land der ersten rum kommt.
Ja was haben sie denn so beantragt.
Also was wir so sozusagen von von anfang an,
uns auf die fahne geschrieben haben wir haben einen antrag gestellt der ultraviolett spektren von heißen weißen zwergen,
um solche ultraviolett schmeckt und von heißen weißen zwerge zu bekommen dass man das ist unser interesse nach wie vor unter unser interesse wir sind also interessiert dann kompakten sternen wie man sagt also stern,
also sterne die jetzt am ende ihres lebens stehen um die chemisch zu analysieren brauchen wir ultraviolett speck drin und das war so eines unserer ersten ziele die wir mit dem teleskop angegangen sind.
Warum braucht man ultraviolett späteren warum denn die anderen nicht.
Also bei diesen heißen sternen um die es hier geht die senden
den größten teil ihrer ihrer strahlung im ultraviolett und röntgen bereich aus und die sind sozusagen im optischen spektral bereich einerseits relativ fenster die kann man nur schwer sehen
auf der anderen seite ist die hauptinsel aktion in den spektrum auch im v spektral bereich zu finden weil bei diesem heißen sternen jetzt,
bestimmte atome in hohen stufen sind und die entsprechenden,
total linien die spektral signatur und die wir suchen sind nur spektral bereich vorhanden.
Okay eines der.
Bekanntesten teil projekte denke ich bei habe ist diese idee doch mal das auge auf einen teil des universums zu richten der aus unserer damaligen beobachtung heraus,
nichts enthielt.
Einfach einen schwarzen fleck wo man mit allen teleskopen mit dem er bisher irgendwie drauf geschaut hat einfach gar nichts gesehen hat was er da so ein bisschen auch so die die fragestellung aufwirft so gibt's irgendwo,
also man hat sich quasi auf die suche nach dem nach dem nichts gemacht und festgestellt dass nichts scheint so nicht zu geben.
Da
Wer hat das überhaupt losgetreten müssen sie das.
Ich glaube es war damals eine der der direktorin oder der direktor des das beste instituts gewesen der.
Halt seine kollegen überredet hat ja wir müssen so eine suche mal machen auch was nicht auch wenn nicht klar ist was da rauskommt das problem ist eben es ist dafür sehr viel beobachtung,
draufgegangen wenn man so sagen will also da würde für viele wochen halt in eine bestimmte richtung des himmels geschaut wo man eben meinte da ist nix,
und nochmal nachzuschauen.
Und viele wochen ist so richtig teuer in gewisser.
Das ist so richtig teuer ich glaube es war ich glaube es war insgesamt ein halbes jahr gewesen was so in der summe dieses teleskope in eine bestimmte richtung geschaut hat ne ja genau.
Nur an einen einzigen ort ein halbes jahr und normalerweise kriegt man vielleicht ist man froh wenn man irgendwie ein tag kriegt oder so.
Ja also üblicherweise werden die ist die einheit sozusagen die zeit einheit beim teleskop ein orbit das ist also die um laufzeit des des clubs um,
um die erde raum also typen typischerweise so eine stunde beobachtungsstelle mit dem teleskop,
und wenn man guten antrag schreibt man,
vielleicht mal zehn arbeit zwanzig arbeits aber das ist schon sehr sehr.
Das waren viele orte.
Das waren viele das waren dann sehr viele arbeit gewesen und ja wie sie sagten nun das ziel
war also schon also man hat schon erwartet dass da jetzt irgendwas zu sehen ist und man hat da diesen dunklen fleck hat sich ausgesucht um dann objekte zu finden die,
licht schwach sind die ansonsten so überstrahlt werden von helleren objekten ja und welche objekt erwartet man sind eben zum beispiel sterne in unserer eigenen galaxis dieser leucht schwach sind sogenannte gute zwerge oder braune zwerge,
die man sehen wollte.
Wie groß war denn dieser wie eng muss man sich jetzt diese diese fokussierung vorstellen ist auf den normalen sternenhimmel schaue wie klein ist dieser bereich der kiste abgeht.
Ich bin jetzt nicht ganz sicher aber er kann nicht besonders groß sein wenn das wenn der bereich so groß war wie meine was der vollmond den man am himmel sieht dann ist das schon ziemlich groß also wahrscheinlich wartebereich deutlich kleiner.
Ja mehr so ein krater.
Was ist denn mehr oder weniger großer krater das ist richtig.
Ja na gut immerhin schon mal etwas was man so mit dem bloßen auge naja so gerade soeben ansatzweise überhaupt.
So auflösen kann ja.
Okay das heißt so ein kleines schwarzes ding hat man sich rausgesucht.
Das hat man sich raus geguckt und das andere was man eben sehen wollte sind sehr weit entfernte galaxien also läuft sprache galaxien die auch sonst halt überstrahlt werden von heller.
Aber wo hat man denn hingeguckt weil das dann sozusagen in die milchstraße hinein oder eher aus diesem aus dieser milchstraßen ebene heraus und vertikal dazu.
Ja man muss also aus der milchstraße im schnitt mit straßen immer mehr oder weniger vertikal rausgucken weil ansonsten die anzahl der sterne wenn man also in die milchstraße ebene hinein schaut die ständig zu hell sind und man nicht wirklich weit gucken kann.
Okay also man hat auch schon ein den möglichst den dunkelsten ort gesund.
Ein wo man bisher nichts gesehen hat sondern wo man auch davon ausgehen kann dass da.
Da ist nix hell ist dazwischen sozusagen was die anderen schwachen objekte über strahlen kann.
Was kann dann raus nach dem heim ja.
Na ja was man da eben gefunden hat das sind sehr weit entfernte galaxien deutsch mache galaxien,
sehr weit entfernt heißt also wenn wir jetzt mal so in die expansion des universum sich zurückdenke das sind also objekte die.
Erstmal weit im fernsehen und deshalb relativ.
Alt sind ne wir gucken ja wenn wir wenn wir weit entfernte objekte anschauen auch in die vergangenheit zurück das heißt was man da sieht sind galaxien die,
relativ jung sind gemessen an dem an dem ur knallt den der damals stattgefunden hat das sind also galaxien die jetzt jugendliches alter haben und man was man was ein da natürlich interessiert ist,
wie haben sich galaxien überhaupt entwickelt was so wie sind galaxien entstanden und wie haben sie sich entwickelt.
Kann man das mal kurz qualifizieren was jugendliches alter auf universums skala bedeutet also ich glaube nur knall wird derzeit so auf dreizehn komma sieben milliarden taxifahrt.
Ja ihre.
Und man kommt also mit dem teleskop wenn man also diese extreme richtung macht ich schätze mal so auf zehn milliarden lichtjahren entfernung das heißt das ist also das sind jetzt alle galaxien die im alter von drei oder vier milliarden jahren nach dem knall haben.
Also gerade zu teenager.
Total teenager galaxien ne so aber nicht wirklich teenager weil dann also zeigen die die bildung der galaxien schon zu diesem zeitpunkt nach dem brutal abgeschlossen ist also den dient das
das eigentliche entstehen der galaxien die kann man mit dem teleskop auch nicht erreichen.
Das führt sozusagen schon in die nächste richtung in die nächste generation von weltraum gruppen mit dem man halt dann diese galaxien entstehung wirklich,
sehen will und beobachten lassen.
Heute ist bemerkenswerter in diesem foto was ja letzten endes entstand oder das war ja das aus diesem schwarzen fleck auf einmal so eine suppe von galaxien wollen.
Ja also da da ist total was los überall wimmelt was wenn man sich das anschaut.
So ein bisschen sowie fisch wasser so wenn man das so das mikrofon legt vorher denkt man sich so ja,
bisschen trüb und dann merkt man so überall tummelt sich irgendwas.
Genau.
Was hat das bewirkt in der wissenschaft also ich mal hat man damit so gerechnet oder war das einfach eine totale überraschung.
Ähm also ich glaube nicht dass es jetzt eine totale überraschung war es ist ja es ist ja schon klar die galaxien die die wir heute sehen die müssen irgendwie entstanden sein und man kann sich.
Man hat jetzt verschiedene theorien wie die galaxien sich entwickelt haben und naja man sieht halt schon die weit entfernten galaxis man weiß schon da musste jetzt irgendwie was da sein.
Na gut aber auch in der menge.
Was die menge der an der galaxien angeht ja ich glaube das war jetzt auch nicht so die ganz große überraschung gewesen aber das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt auf mein nicht unbedingt mein fachgebiet,
ja aber wie gesagt ich glaube einfach dass diese beobachtungen die teleskop gemacht worden sind auch schon sozusagen grundlage die grundlage,
gebildet hat für das was man jetzt demnächst zum beispiel mit dem james wetter,
sich anschauen will wo man also jetzt wirklich weiter zurückgehen will in den zeit,
richtung knall wie halt die struktur bildung des universums.
Wie die stattgefunden hat.
Schauen wir doch vielleicht nochmal auf das vermächtnis von kabel und was jetzt diese lange betriebs phase von na immerhin von zwanzig.
Neunundzwanzig.
Ne aber war ja ja okay gut mit der spektrum kopie ich bin jetzt von dreiundneunzig okay also wir haben jetzt quasi so drei jahrzehnte,
was ja auch eine bemerkenswerte laufzeit ist für so ein komplexes gerät was nur so den ersten zehn jahren wirklich,
überarbeitet worden und gewartet werden konnte seitdem ist eine ganze menge gelaufen was sind denn so die.
Die großen beiträge die dieses weltraum teleskop jetzt für die allgemeine erkenntnis über unsere welt wo gefüttert.
Ja also wenn man das nicht so anschaut das teleskop hat sozusagen geben teilbereich der gastronomie,
zum teil eben auch wirklich revolutioniert aber eben viele neue erkenntnisse gebracht und es gibt natürlich jetzt ein paar highlights die man darstellen kann das eine ist natürlich jetzt die bestimmung,
genauere bestimmung der havel konstanten ähm was also jetzt für das weltall der wichtig ist aber.
Was was man denn jetzt über die über die konstanten weil es ist ja nicht so konstant.
Ja die das wusste man ja schon vorher dass die hammel konstante nicht konstant ist die das ist.
Aber sie heißt trotzdem noch.
Die heißt immer noch so ja weil man eben annimmt dass die halbe konstante überall im raum liegt die gleiche sozusagen ist aber die ist natürlich zeitlich abhängig aber,
was eben jetzt was in die ganz große überraschung waren dass es sich eines der highlights was mit dem kabel teleskop gebracht worden ist ist die erkenntnis dass das universum halt,
die expansion des universums nicht abgebremst ist obwohl's halt immer gedacht hat weil die gravitation jetzt der expansion entgegenwirkt sondern dass im gegenteil die expansion beschleunigt ist ja das ist also was eine entdeckung die,
komplett unerwartet kam.
Und dafür gab es ja auch die nobelpreises vor fünfzehn jahren oder sowas was dann zu dem konzept der dunklen energie geführt hat dass er letztendlich unsere universum,
die vorherrschende form von matthias energien uns in unserem universum,
durch die dunkle energie ausgemacht wird,
letztendlich hat die sagen wir mal das handy und eine,
erkenntnis gebracht oder sagen wir mal etwas für uns in die welt gebracht was man eigentlich nicht kennt also es hat keine sozusagen.
Eine neue unkenntnis.
Ist eine neue unkenntnis geschafft geschaffen wenn man so will ne also das ist ein das ist ja auch so so ganz interessant weil das ist sicher eines der ganz großen ergebnisse die man damit habe gefunden hat
und das ist eben nur dadurch gelungen dass man jetzt von diesen selfie eben als entfernung indikatoren über die wir gerade gesprochen haben,
abkommen konnte und daneben standard kerzen beobachten konnte die noch heller sind als die chefin dass man die also noch weiter im universum beobachten können dass.
Was heißt das das heißt standard kerzen jetzt keine kerzen im weltall sondern das.
Ja das ist halt nicht so.
Kann man überhaupt von von etwas sagen wie weit es weg ist.
Genau also man,
wenn man wissen will wie weit entfernt ein ein bestimmter stern ist da muss ich wissen wie wie wie läuft kräftig einstellen ist also wie hell einen stern ist ja wie viel energie ja pro sekunde ausstrahlt und bei den preisen wissen wir das ganz genau,
und zwar über den umweg dass wir also messen wie,
periode der helligkeit veränderung dieser sterne ist also wir wissen dass diese sterne.
Wie wir sagen toren sind das sind also objekte die sich regelmäßig ausdehnen und zusammenziehen und aus der periode dieses dieses ausdehnung und zusammenziehen prozesses kann man auf die leuchtkraft schließen.
Woher weiß man das denn also dass das wirklich so gleich förmlich ist.
Das kann man jetzt schließen aus der tatsache dass man eben,
solche c beobachtet in einem bestimmten galaxien deren abstände man kennt ja sich und das also geschichtlich ist es so man hat die große magische wolke hergenommen eine unserer nachbar galaxien,
man weiß also dass alle diese objekte die immer da beobachtet in einer ganz bestimmten entfernung stehen die man jetzt auf eine art und weise noch bestimmen kann und dann müsste man jetzt die pulsationen perioden dieser sterne,
und weiß und hat gefunden dass die pulsationen perioden mit der leuchtkraft dieser sterne zusammenhängt.
Und man kann also aus der messung dieser positionspapier und auf die helligkeit schließen,
und man weiß eben dann wie hält diese sterne sind und das ist halt dann so die standard kerze die man da benutzt.
Man kann wirklich von den von den paar stern auf alle schließen weil sich das sozusagen.
Ja da also da das ist natürlich jetzt auch eine gewisse hoffnung erstmal die man haben kann weil es ist eben so dass wenn man sich das im detail anguckt wenn man also jetzt wirklich detaillierte messung machen will,
dann hängt diese positionen periode eben nicht nur einfach mit der leuchtkraft der sterne zusammen sondern eben auch mit der chemischen zusammensetzung dieser sterne und man weiß eben dass die chemische zusammensetzung in unserer galaxie anders sein kann,
als die chemischen zusammensetzung der stern in anderen galaxien aber das sind so effekte effekte die man auch noch herausfinden kann und in die solche rechnung mit reinsteckt.
Ja und andere so die,
anderen oder die anderen standard kerzen die man jetzt her genommen hat um die expansion die beschleunigte expansion des universums zu bestimmen sind halt die super nordsee also stern explosion eines bestimmten typs dieser typ eins a super
von denen man auch weiß oder zumindest ein gute ernährung angeben,
kann das wenn man eine solche super nova beobachtet dass sie einen bestimmten energie output hast das heißt man weiß auch die haben eine bestimmte helligkeit,
und je weiter diese sterne diese super nobel von uns entfernt sind.
Du leucht sprecher erscheinen sie uns ne man hat also wieder so eine standard kerze die also heller ist als diese,
die man also in noch weiter entfernten galaxien bestimmen kann.
Das heißt der typ super nur wer die man sozusagen erstmal unterscheiden kann in seiner eigentlichen ausprägung man sieht also okay hier findet genau eine explosion dieses typs.
Und die ist sozusagen durch,
dadurch dass sie in diesem typ stattfinden kann es relativ klar gesagt in welchem energiebereich sich das sozusagen abspielen und damit hat man quasi eine enorme auf eine helligkeit und dann die eigentlich gemessene helligkeit kann man dann mehr oder weniger direkt,
in relation setzen so okay umso dunkler du bist umso weiter bist du,
weil ich weiß einfach wie hell du sein muss damit du das tust was du gerade machst nämlich auf diese bestimmte art und weise zu explodieren okay da sagt man statt als kerze so wie halt das,
die maßeinheit candela ja sozusagen auch die basis der der leuchtet helligkeit ist.
Leute ich greife.
Okay das heißt man hat jetzt einfach an verschiedenen stellen geschaut und dann einfach über die zeit genug solche super novelle gesehen das poppen die am laufenden meter hoch oder ist es eher eine seltene geschichte.
Na sagen wir mal so vor zehn fünfzehn jahren waren diese objekte noch noch nicht so häufig beobachtet weil die leuchten dann in irgendwelchen galaxien auf und man muss dann so zeit zum richtigen zeitpunkt hingucken auf diese galaxie
so dass das früher also,
waren für unsere beobachtung wie man relativ selten gefunden hat vielleicht einmal im monat oder irgendwie sowas,
aber in der zwischenzeit seit etwa zehn jahren gibt es dann sucht programme,
das sind also dann teleskope die nacht für nacht viele galaxien sich anschauen und fotografieren und einfach mal gucken ob da irgendwas los ist was was man sonst da nicht sieht also die suchen dann wirklich an nach solchen sterne explosion
in einer vielzahl von galaxien pro nacht und durch diese super nova sucht programme,
sind da jetzt so viele objekte die man pro nacht neu entdeckt ich würde mal schätzen mindestens eins vielleicht sogar zehn super nordsee die man die man pro nacht in solchen,
galaxien finden.
Oha schwer was los im.
Da ist immer was los.
Okay das heißt umso mehr man solche sachen auch hat umso mehr kann man dann andere messungen auch wieder in relation setzen und sozusagen noch weiter verfeinern.
So und das heißt man hat wenn ich das richtig sehe,
gestellt das umso weiter etwas weg ist.
Umso schneller fliegt es davon.
Ja also die wenn ich mir jetzt so eine weit entfernte super normaler weit entfernten galaxie anschaue dann ist die helligkeit die scheinbare helligkeit dieser super nova.
Geringer ist also dunkler.
Als das was ich mit dem normalen handel gesetzt ohne dunkle energie annehmen würde das heißt also diese super nur weiß weiter entfernt als ich annehme weiter entfernt.
Als wenn ich einfach nur die annahme machen dass das universum expandiert und vielleicht langsam abgebremst wird so diese dinge sind also weiter entfernt was man da nur so interpretieren kann dass wir keine ab bremsung haben sondern 'ne beschleunigung.
Also die sind dunkler als man eigentlich erwartet diese beide entfernten super.
Also die sind dunkler sind weiter entfernt und deshalb muss man da eben expandiert zusätzliche beschleunigung.
Das heißt man weiß jetzt einfach irgendwann ist alles so weit weg dass wir es gar nicht mehr sehen.
Richtig ja das ist sozusagen der horizont bis zu dem wir sehen kann weil einfach das licht.
Von diesen objekten nicht mehr die zeit hat sozusagen zu erreichen weil das die expansion des raumes zwischen uns und der lichtquelle da die expansion geschwindigkeit größer ist als die licht geschwindigkeit.
Also wir haben einen bestimmten horizont bis zu dem wir gucken können aber wir wissen jenseits dieses horizonte sind noch andere objekte.
Und wenn man sich jetzt mal diese beschleunigte expansion des universums waren die jetzt mal so in die zukunft sich vorstellt was da passiert ist dann heißt es eben dass die,
gastronomen zukünftiger generationen das für die dieser licht horizont,
sozusagen immer kleiner wird das heißt die können also irgendwann mal.
Und ja das kann man so hoch rechnen dass es in vielen milliarden von jahren sozusagen,
die erste normen die dann in der zukunft beobachten nicht mehr die weit entfernten galaxien sehen sondern nur noch die galaxien in der luft der lokal galaxien gruppe.
Das heißt wir müssen gucken das weltall.
Zu beobachten bevor alles hinter dem licht horizont verschwindet.
Ja wenn man nicht zu dem zeitpunkt schon wieder ganz andere erkenntnisse hat wie man sozusagen aus paralleluniversum umschalten.
Ja
Was könnte habe dennoch,
liefern außer dieser ausdehnung des universums also es war ja auch im bereich der beobachtung von,
himmels körpern unseres sonnensystems,
auch sehr hilfreich weil weit gucken bis galaxien die sehr weit weg sind klar alles super
so also wir haben ja auch noch ein paar objekte in unserem sonnensystem die wir so bisher nur mit detaillierten missionen haben sehen können also vor allem dass ich die namen
planeten wenn man jetzt mit habel auf den mund oder auf den mars schaut da kriegt man ja doch schon relativ detaillierte bilder.
Das ist richtig ab.
Ja und das betrifft halt dann insbesondere die objekte ihr am rande uns unseres sonnensystem stehen also weit entfernte asteroiden,
die wir erst mal so mit weltraum fahrzeugen nicht so ohne weiteres besuchen können also und,
also praktisch alles was wir heute wissen über objekte trans napoleonischen objekte oder sowas jetzt mal mit,
ausnahme von pluto die ganzen erkenntnisse die wir davon haben sind jetzt nicht nur vom havel teleskope mit optischen teleskopen auf der erde gewonnen worden,
ja und es wird halt in der nahen zukunft so sein an dieser situation wird sich nichts ändern weil,
wie wir alle wissen so diese institut beobachtung von weit entfernten asteroiden und äh trans nett und objekten halt etwas ist,
was sehr lange dauert also die reisenden mission war zehn jahre unterwegs gewesen von der erde bis zum pluto und war auch nicht ganz billig gewesen das heißt sowas kann man sich nicht jederzeit leisten um solche weit entfernten objekt
zu zu ergründen und das teleskop hat eben durch seine beobachtung,
uns viele erkenntnisse über die transnationale objekt gebracht beziehungsweise solche transatlantischen objekte erstmal nur aufgefunden die wir vorher nicht kann.
Also hört er iris schon dazu näheres hat man glaube ich vorher schon gesehen es gibt ja eine ganze reihe,
von objekten diese rund um den pluto herum oder sagen wir mal außerhalb des neptun so sagt ja der name,
herum düsen was ja letzten endes außer degradieren von pluto geführt hat weil man einfach gesehen hat so wurden ja okay
nicht immer für den planeten gehalten aber sowas besonderes bis jetzt nicht weil so von deiner art und weise straucheln sträuche da so einiges herum,
aber habe war ja dann sozusagen auch extrem hilfreich so in dieser mission,
gerade bei dieser new reisende mission,
waren ja glaube ich die gabel bilder vom pluto sozusagen die beste vorgabe die man hat um um überhaupt erstmal in etwa zu wissen was da ein erwartet,
aber dann ja auch in der folge ich hatte ja hier vor zwei drei ausgaben martin petzold sehr ausführlich über diese mission gesprochen,
nachdem er erfolgreicher pluto vorbeigeflogen ist hat man gleich das nächste objekt in angriff genommen ultimatum coole wurde es dann genannt was mit habel dann überhaupt erst gefunden wurde.
Richtig ja ne und so viel ich weiß eben die ähm.
Hat man die drei historie auf der man dann zum pluto geführt hat eben auch äh sozusagen korrigiert auf,
auf die position die von pluto die man eben mit dem kabel teleskop gemessen hat,
und eben nicht nur den pluto sondern auch die monde vom bluetooth mussten also die wurden ja auch von der jury beobachtet und da musste man ja vorher auch wissen wo stehen die monde zu dem zeitpunkt der ernährung die,
nächste annäherung hat nur ein paar stunden gedauert man muss da so sehr genau wissen wo stehen die monde auf ihrem orbit und wo muss ich die kameras ausrichten.
Dass man in einen rein knallt oder auch nur von den nennenswert abgelenkt wird so.
Das ist das eine aber dass man eben einfach nur mit seinen kameras sozusagen in die falsche richtung hält und da dahin guckt wo der mond gar nicht steht auch nicht.
Das für die paar minuten die man hat das wäre so ein bisschen doof.
Wie sie das mit excel planeten außer gibt es ja defizite teleskope,
die sich jetzt eigentlich genau nur darauf konzentriert haben ein voran das das käppeler tedesco passels leider nicht mehr funktioniert,
wurde mit hoppel auch versucht in dem bereich um was zu unternehmen.
Also das käppeler teleskop und jetzt um nachfolge projekt wie test zum beispiel was jetzt gerade von der nasa,
seit einem jahr betrieben wird
da geht es erstmal nur darum diese diese planeten zu entdecken über die transit methode und in die planeten ziehen vor den mutter stern vorbei und aus diesem grunde werden die mutter sterne etwas schwächer man müsste.
Und kann auf diese art und weise erstmal gucken wo welche sterne haben planeten die man,
vielleicht jetzt sich später nochmal aufs korn nehmen kann und da kommt im jetzt das teleskop ins spiel wo man versucht etwas mehr über die physik dieser planeten herauszubekommen,
was da zum beispiel mit dem teleskop gemacht werden kann was eben mit kappler oder test nicht gemacht wird dass man spektrums kopie von diesen explodiert planeten macht und nachgucken will,
welche,
chemischen elemente sind eigentlich in den in den exel planeten atmosphären und das kann man eben nur durch spektrums kopie machen in dem augenblick wo also die planeten vor dem mutter stern vorbeiziehen und das,
sterne nämlich durch die planeten atmosphäre durchgeht und dem,
sozusagen die planeten atmosphäre diesen stern licht bestimmte spektral signaturen aufgeprägt das ist das was man als trans mission spektrums kopie bezeichnet und da hat,
habel eben bestimmte messungen machen können von bestimmten excel planeten und bestimmt na ja wir finden wasserstoff oder bestimmte metalle kalzium magnesium in diesen planeten,
atmosphäre und das ist was was also wirklich nur mit dem handel teleskop gefunden werden kann.
Also diese planeten forschung wird so auf physikalischer seite wenn man herausfinden will
unter umständen sind diese planeten haben die atmosphäre die lebens freundlich sind dass das gelingt also dann nur durch durch eine spektrums kopie und habe macht er den anfang,
und man ist mit dem handel teleskoplader ziemlich am limit weil es eben nach heutigen maßstäben das relativ kleinen spiegel hat und man eigentlich mit dieser transformation spiritus kopie nur wirklich vorankommt wenn man,
in zukunft machen teleskop hat was doch deutlich größer als habe ist.
Ja das ist sozusagen stand heute wir nehmen die sendung hier im oktober zwanzig neunzehn auf.
Habe läuft noch es funktioniert eigentlich auch noch äh im wesentlichen alles,
allerdings gab es schon so ein paar schwäche phasen also von dem glaub ich insgesamt sechs groß gruppen die
zur stabilisierung also sozusagen zur eigenen orientierung im raum
die ja nicht ganz unwichtig ist wenn man irgendwo scharf hingucken möchte die also dort eingebaut sind sind dann mehr als eigentlich vorgesehen gleichzeitig ausgefallen gewesen das war ja letztes jahr,
was ist denn da genau passiert und wie konnte das wieder behoben werden.
Ich glaube der stand der dinge ist so dass von diesen sechs kreisen inzwischen drei ausgefallen sind und man braucht also im prinzip drei kreisel um die raum richtung genau zu bestimmen das teleskop in bestimmte raum richtung aus zu,
auszurichten,
und ähm das könnt ihr natürlich sein dass jetzt in in der zukunft noch ein weiterer kreisel ausfällt dann hat man nur noch zwei und dann haben wir ein problem.
Aber war das nicht schon so dass genau einer zuviel ausgefallen ist.
Da bin ich jetzt nicht ganz sicher das kann ich ihnen jetzt nicht sagen aber man hat zumindest prozedur entwickelt dass man auch mit zwei,
büros gruppen das teleskop steuern kann und das ist jetzt also etwas was man gelernt hat schon mit den vorgehen,
vorgänger teleskopen dieses eu was wir ganz am anfang angesprochen haben das war so ein satelliten ende glaube ich nur noch in einem boot gelaufen ist er mit einem büros grob gesteuert werden konnte also man hat dann schon,
so vielen jahrzehnten solche prozedur entwickelt wie man ein weltraum fitnessclub auch mit weniger als drei gruppen,
steuern kann das geht zum beispiel mit magnetfeld messgeräten also die magnetfeld,
messgeräten die sich jetzt aus orientieren an dem magnetfeld der erde so was kann man da so machen und das hat man im prinzip weil das habe ich schon entwickelt das heißt also wenn da jetzt noch ein kreisel ausfällt das wäre jetzt erstmal keine,
katastrophe und ich glaube ich eher entsinne mich dran erst im oktober letzten jahres glaub ich einer dieser,
drei verbliebenen kreisen schon ausgefallen ist das kein problem aber ich glaube den konnte man wieder anwerfen.
Ja ich glaube da wurde wieder frei.
Ja da wurde irgendwie so was genau das funktioniert also das war jetzt erstmal kein katastrophaler fehler wenn das nochmal passieren wird.
Ist ja egal interessant wie sozusagen was er alles für,
ja für hacker methoden auf einmal aufgerufen werden müssen um in solchen fällen dann,
aus dem was man eben hat und das ist ja sozusagen man kann ja nichts mehr hinbringen,
man muss ja mit dem arbeiten was da ist wie man sozusagen auch ganz neue ansätze,
schafft es nicht sogar so dass diese korrektur optik die installiert wurde also die brille in anführungsstrichen irgendwann auch gar nicht mehr benötigt wurde und das sozusagen über die instrumente selber geregelt wurde.
Ja genau also diese optik die ist inzwischen auf der erde wieder gelandet die hat man rausgenommen aus dem handel teleskop,
bei der letzten service mission als man einen bestimmten spektrum grafen eingebaut hat den hat man dann die position eingebaut wo diese korrektur optik saß
die haben die erste mal mit dem shuttle zurückgebracht die kann man in irgendeinen amerikanischen beziehung.
Ja warum brauchte man die dann nicht mehr.
Ja die brauchte man nicht mehr weil man sozusagen diese korrektur optik schon in diese instrumente die man da neu installiert hatte integriert hat.
Und deshalb alle instrumente fünf instrumente die heute am heißt wie laufen das sind also instrumente die nach sozusagen nach der nach der ersten.
Also die speziell sozusagen auf diesen blick fehler hin optimiert wurden.
Genau richtig.
Was hat man dadurch gewonnen also wo es dann noch genauer dadurch oder.
Durch neue.
Man hätte die brille auch aber da lassen können.
Man sieht da lassen können aber die braucht platz in der ebene des,
obst und diesen platz hat man eben jetzt benutzt um einen weiteren spektrum grafen einzug.
Ach so wenn man dazu sagen ein instrument drauf verzichten muss.
Genau also diese korrektur linse eingebaut worden ist muss man dafür ein an ein bestimmtes instrument opfern was man dann weggenommen hat.
Pfiffige lösungsansätze auf jeden fall ja trotzdem lang macht das nicht mehr oder doch man weiß es nicht kann morgen vorbei sein kann aber auch noch zehn jahre halten.
Das könnte noch zehn jahre halten ja also die sagen wir mal heute sind die leute relativ optimistisch weil alle instrumente eilig stabil laufen.
Also erstmal eine kamera war mal die elektronik ein bisschen ausgefallen aber inzwischen glaubt man also wenn man weiß nie genau in dem geschäft natürlich aber dass das teleskop vielleicht noch
fünf bis zehn jahre,
leben kann und so produkte sozusagen wissenschaft produzieren kann wie das heute der fall ist aber der eigentlich limitierte faktor ist natürlich dann der,
relativ niedrige erdarbeiten des teleskop s.
Und diese arbeit wird also ständig ständig kleinere das heißt es kommt uns immer näher der erdatmosphäre immer näher und irgendwann,
wird das teleskop halt in die erdatmosphäre eintreten und vergnügen und,
ich glaube diesen zeitpunkt vorherzusagen das ist ein bisschen schwierig das hängt davon ab wie aktiv die sonne ist wie weit ausgedehnt die erdatmosphäre ist,
aber ich glaube spätestens in fünfzehn oder zwanzig jahren wird es dann soweit sein.
Also das ist jetzt schon kein treibstoff mehr gibt oder dass er nur nicht lange halten.
Nicht man hat da hat also kein kein sozusagen keiner paketen antrieb um es in einen höheren orbit zu zu bringen das heißt das kommt zeit das singt einfach im laufe der zeit.
Ohne könnte sein dass du in fünfzehn zwanzig jahren dann in die erdatmosphäre beitritt uns auf dem kopf.
Dann ist weg aber wahrscheinlich nicht auf den kopf sondern eher in irgendein ozean.
Wahrscheinlich.
Was könnte das ja auch noch dieser generation von weltraum fahrzeugen wo sozusagen die außer betriebnahme noch nicht eingebaut ist also es gibt sozusagen noch keine strategie wie man das dann gezielt steuern kann.
Genau das sind halt diese alten sachen wo man sich da damals noch keine gedanken drüber gemacht hat was passiert wenn die runterkommen.
Na ja da sind sie bei der space awareness,
dann immer die hände of kopf.
So jetzt ist es ja so es gibt ja ein.
Oder vielleicht auch mehrere nachfolger also es gibt modernere,
teleskope die andere eine andere ausrichtung haben.
Das wo glaube ich am meisten darüber gesprochen wird ist das sogenannte james web teleskop.
Was ganz gerne mal so als habe nachfolger munde geführt wird aber so ganz stimmt das ja nicht.
Nee so von astronomische seite ist das eigentlich überhaupt keinen nachfolger weil wenn man sich mal anschaut,
welchen wellenlänge bereich habel arbeitet und die wellenlänge reicht das arbeiten wird so sind die also komplett unterschiedlich also das.
Also welches spektrum deckten.
Ist also ein infrarot teleskop und was also mit dem james überhaupt nicht angeguckt wird ist der optische spektral bereich und schon gar nicht der ultraviolett spektral.
Also von daher von von dem business sommer von der wissenschaft oder sagen wir mal von,
von den instrumenten die man benutzen kann ist das teleskop etwas ganz anderes als das haben wir teleskop ist also für uns eigentlich keinen nachfolger.
Warum hat man sich darauf beschränkt.
Ja man hat also,
man wie gesagt am anfang haben wir schon über die technischen möglichkeiten gesprochen mit dem man also mit dem handel teleskop auch im,
infrarot oder piloten schauen kann also mit dem teleskop kommt man nicht ins ferne infrarot.
Da wollen manche astro astro momentan auch arbeiten und dazu ist halt das james des krug.
Darauf ist es optimiert im im fernen infrarot jetzt messung zu machen,
also es sind technische gründe dass dieses teleskop jetzt speziell auf den info-ständen spektral bereich zugeschnitten worden.
Also wie zum beispiel die sektoren die können halt nur infrarot nicht sehen aber eben kein uvp oder ob geschissen.
In frauenbereich ist,
nicht uninteressant und ist natürlich durchaus und für die wissenschaft auch hilfreich mal auf dem auge etwas weniger blind zu sein als man das halt der zeit ist ein anderer interessanter unterschied ist ja dass,
während habel halt im erdogan kreist fit ja,
an einem dieser branche punkte also ein punkt zwei ist das jetzt richtig sehr also hinter der erde da wo auch schon herrsche,
und plank ihr unwesen getrieben haben
da ist halt schon dunkel man sieht halt immer mit der erde mit weil man sozusagen in diesem sich ausgleichende gravitationswellen loch drin hängt und dann
einfach mehr oder weniger somit geschoben wird ohne dass man da ist noch eine zusätzliche beschleunigung braucht es ja gibt ja extrem viele mission die sich auf diesen bereich konzentriert haben in letzter zeit eben genau aus diesen effekt
ja schön kalt ist irgendwie so dunkel wie man's braucht man hat nicht so eine strahlende erde das ist ja auch für habel sicherlich ein problem.
Dass die erde einfach die ganze zeit mit leuchtet wenn man so in dunkle gucken will dann ist das irgendwie so eine helle erde ist nicht schön oder.
Ist nicht gut ne.
Aber trotzdem was es zu erwarten was was man mit diesem.
Sehen kann weil der spiegel ist ja extrem viel größer als der von habe.
Ja das ich weiß die genaue zahl nicht aber sowas wie ein sechseinhalb meter,
ist also deutlich größer als das havel teleskop.
Und naja so die eine der wissen großen wissenschaftlichen zielsetzung ist halt dass man in dem info roten spektral bereich.
Jetzt besonders hoch rot verschoben galaxien sehen kann also dass man da jetzt in großen distanzen die jetzt die galaxien geordnet beobachtet die gerade im entstehen sind dass es so eines der wichtigsten,
zielsetzung von james dass man dieses zusammensetzen der aufbau der galaxien wie die entstehen halt.
Also die richtigen baby galaxien wo wir vorhin drüber gesprochen hatten die eben dadurch dass sie sehr jung sind sehr weit weg sind.
Und deswegen sozusagen auch am am weitesten weg beschleunigt sind und dann eben durch diesen doppler,
effekt der licht beobachtung das was man in der nähe noch im sichtbaren,
licht bereich gehabt hätte dadurch dass sich ebenso weg schiebt ins rot und damit eben immer tiefer ins infrarot hinein schiebt das heißt,
das ist sozusagen der besonderes bin dass wenn man jetzt so hoch auflösen im infrarot hineinschauen kann dass man eben so diese ganz alte sachen sieht also sozusagen das universum auf seite eins aufschlag.
Genau.
Ja und eine andere sache ist man das jetzt nicht zu diesen ganz großen distanzen geht wenn man wieder zu den planeten in unserer galaxie geht das soll hätte dann solche spektrums kopie von planeten atmosphären machen in einem stil,
was also jetzt mit dem teleskop gerade angegangen wird aber dadurch dass das james web hat einen größeren
spiegel hat kann man also diese spektrum tropischen untersuchung genauer machen und damit chemische analysen von planeten,
atmosphären besser weitaus besser durchführen als das was man heute mit kabel kann.
Ja aber ich merke schon so ein bisschen so richtig glücklich sind sie nicht mit nur james web weil wenn er mal runterfällt dann ist halt der tolle uvp bericht ist wieder weg,
jetzt sozusagen überhaupt gar keine alternativen oder gibt es noch teleskopie zumindest teilbereiche abdecken oder es irgendwas in arbeit.
Ne also wenn man von teleskop ansieht absieht da gibt es kein teleskope was jetzt im vorbereich beobachtet und es ist auch von den großen weltraum agenturen,
nichts geplant ist auch nichts in der pipeline was da kommen könnte.
Oder sagen wir mal es wird schon geplant aber es ist nichts beschlossen also und jetzt gibt es also in den usa gibt es eine initiative.
Sozusagen einen richtigen habel nachfolger zu bauen in dem sinne dass der wellenlänge im bereich der gleiche sein soll wie bei dem havel aber das sozusagen jetzt nur der spiegel größer ist das
jetzt einen spiegel teleskop konstruiert das was vielleicht oder teleskope konstruiert was ein spiegel durchmesser von zehn vielleicht sechzehn meter hat
und da gibt es jetzt von der nasa seite her so eine studie gemacht über so ein großes ev,
teleskop aber da ist noch nichts beschlossen und das bedeutet also wenn man sich überlegt auf welches skalen diese,
projekte verwirklicht werden selbst wenn man heute beschließt einen solchen krabbeln nachfolger zu bauen wird es fünfzehn oder wahrscheinlich eher zwanzig jahre dauern,
bist du ein solches teleskop auch fliegt.
Muss erstmal erfunden werden muss dass man konzipiert werden muss man sich gedanken darüber machen was will man eigentlich drin haben was kriegt man noch rein was kriegt man finanziert dann muss es gebaut werden.
Ja
Dann muss es getestet werden und da muss auch noch funktionieren.
Ja ne wir wissen eben aus den erfahrungen von habel oder von dem james teleskop ist also eigentlich von allem großteil des gruppen,
dass die vorlaufzeiten von etwa fünfzehn oder zwanzig jahren haben und das heißt also wenn das teleskop morgen ausfällt ist sozusagen für die astronom das uvp fenster zum universum geschlossen.
Wenn sie gleich in rente gehen sozusagen das war's.
Oder ich mache eine andere wissenschaft.
Ist ja noch genug übrig okay,
ist jetzt auch nicht so dass halt sozusagen keiner drüber nachdenkst ja auch schon mal interessant.
Was könnte man sich denn also was sind denn sozusagen.
Und vielleicht nochmal so zum zum schluss auch noch mal so ein bisschen an die grenzen oder so ein bisschen die grenzen von habe zu verstehen also was jetzt und wünsch dir was habe zwei.
Wir haben mit wegen mit dem zehn meter spiegel und dann schickt man es vielleicht auch noch an diesen lange punkt wo man so schön im dunklen und ohne leuchtende erde daneben ist was was wäre denn so ihre erwartung.
Auf auf welchem faktor ist vielleicht ein bisschen groß aber so.
Wie umfangreich kann man sich sozusagen die veränderung der wahrnehmung eines solchen gerätes an modernen des clubs dieser ähnlichen bauart vorstellen also welchen,
erkenntnis gewinnen würde man sicher erwarten und wo fängt es an dann wieder interessante an uns zu geben die man vielleicht tangieren.
Ja
Immer ein bisschen schwierig das.
Spielst du aber,
ja das ist richtig aber man muss irgendwie davon ausgehen wenn man versuchen will jetzt wieder geld zu bekommen für ein solches projekt da muss man auch schon ewig.
Der gute fragen formulieren und sagen,
der erkenntnis gewinnen den man durch ein solches teures objekt oder teleskope jetzt hat das ist jetzt nicht nur ein bisschen instrument hell man weiß dann zehn prozent mehr wenn man das ewige quantifizieren kann so man muss schon was machen oder wie sagen ich.
Was neues gerissen wird und das ist eben auch der grund dafür warum das teleskop
dann jetzt praktisch keine kopie von dem havel teleskop werden kann sondern es muss eben mein spiegel haben der von der sammelt fläche vielleicht zehn mal größer ist ja dann weiß ich ich kann zehn mal weiter gucken oder ich kann objekte sehen
mit einer stimme sozusagen mit einer auflösung die zehnmal besser ist und dann kann ich zum beispiel in einem solchen zukünftigen teleskop.
Etwas einbauen was das haben nicht hat zum beispiel ein polar meter dass man also jetzt polarisiert das licht anschauen kann,
und das analysieren kann was also qualitativ was ganz neues ist was man mit dem haben überhaupt nicht machen kann
und das liefert eben ein zum beispiel erkenntnisse über die struktur von magnetfelder n in sternen oder im in darsteller medium
was also qualität für so ein ganz neues fenster aufmachen somit sowas muss man sich überlegen was man mit diesen großen teleskopen machen kann,
einfach um um finanziell jetzt zu rechtfertigen oder zu rechtfertigen man muss diese oder man sollte jetzt diese kosten dafür tragen.
Und gibt's dann.
Gibt es noch irgendwo eine frage die jetzt im raum rumhängen ich meine wenn man ursprünglich an start,
gesagt hat hier hab ich konstante das muss jetzt mal ganz genau vorstellen,
wäre es jetzt eher so die suche nach der dunklen energie auf die man jetzt neue antworten durch so ein titel,
erhalten könnte oder ist es dann doch eher eine frage für die
für die zahnarzt abteilung wo partikel beschleunigt werden müssen,
um diese fragen zu beantworten gibt 's andere fragen die sich aufdrängen und die man dann sozusagen unmittelbar jetzt mal lösen möchte.
Ja klar so dunkle energie und dunkle materie ist eben das was gerade so um sozusagen lieben
das was auf den auf den nägeln brennt während bei der dunklen materie könnte ich mir vorstellen das ist jetzt eher etwas was konzern kommen was du durch die teilchen beschleunigen kommt weil jeder glaubt na ja das sind halt,
unbekannte elementar teilchen wie noch nicht gefunden haben aber ganz,
komisch wird es eben bei der dunklen energie wo keiner so richtig vorstellung hat.
Was dahinter steckt und ich glaube auf dem gebiet ist es wichtig da also neue beobachtung zu kriegen also irgendwie,
die idee zu haben in welche richtung man überhaupt suchen muss also da wird man mit teilchen beschleunigen glaub ich nichts werden und na ja wie das eben so häufig,
ist so die,
man findet dann eben mit solchen neuen instrumenten dann dinge die man erstmal überhaupt gar nicht erwartet also wenn wir jetzt muss von zu dem teleskop zurück mit der beschleunigten expansion des universum,
universums das sind so grundsätzliche dinge an die hat man überhaupt noch nicht gedacht dass ich wieder gestartet worden ist und ich glaube es sind,
ich glaube ich glaube einfach das sind so die.
Einfach nur das potenzial dass man da etwas schafft was neue dinge entdecken kann dann die man überhaupt noch nicht denkt ich glaube das ist da.
So was ganz entscheidend ist was hinter diesen großen projekten steht also das will ich was neues finden woran wir gar nicht denken.
Und so teuer sind die eigentlich gar nicht wenn man immer mit dem preis von durchschnittlichen kampfflieger vergleicht.
Ja ich meine das,
james teleskop das ist glaube ich inzwischen bei kosten von zehn milliarden euro oder dollar sowas angestiegen na ja man muss sich überlegen wann gibt es das geld eben auf lange zeit skalen aus die entwicklung zeit war zwanzig jahre das heißt um das,
dann sind es nur noch null komma fünf milliarden pro jahr und wenn man sich diese kosten jetzt auch noch teil zwischen verschiedenen ländern agenturen nasa esa hat dann dann kocht das langsam zu zahlen herunter die jetzt nicht mehr so wahnsinnig,
groß sind sie können das mit solchen militärischen ausgaben vergleichen.
Verschenkt ja auch nicht ich mein es bleibt ja sozusagen auch ein system und erhält ja dann eben auch eine eine interessante industrie.
Ja damit es bleibt halt alles auf der erde und es werden leute dafür bezahlt spezialisten bezahlt und das ist ja nicht sozusagen kamin geschrieben das geld.
Also wir sind uns einig wir wollte was haben und unterstreichen dass an dieser stelle nochmal.
Ja absolut genau.
Ja herr werner gibt's noch irgendwelche letzten folgen.
Nichts.
Feststellung die wir jetzt vielleicht vergessen haben wie man sozusagen auf dieses projekt blicken sollte.
Tja ja volle worte freuen.
Was hast du denn so persönlich was war so ihr persönliches.
In der ganzen auseinandersetzung ja.
Jetzt mit hagel ja also was was wir halt so in letzter zeit machen konnten ist äh dass wir so chemische elemente in,
in diesen weißen zwerg sternen gefunden haben die man also vorher,
in stern überhaupt noch nicht gefunden hat das sind da so jetzt wenn man so als perioden system der elemente,
denkt also objekte die schwere sind als eisen bis hin zu technik wurde solche elemente die wir jetzt in solchen sternen gefunden haben.
Was also wichtig ist um zu entscheiden.
Herauszubekommen wie entstehen eigentlich solche elemente in stern wir wissen dass also alle schweren elemente außer wasserstoff und helium,
oder großer teil in oder um stern entstanden ist und man möchte gerne verstehen mit welcher effizienz jetzt sterne solche diese chemischen elemente bilden,
und das ist für mich also jetzt so was was was ich hier so im nachhinein in den letzten zehn jahren am interessantesten fand dass man eben mit dieser uvp spektrums kopie.
Jetzt vordringen konnte zu besonders schweren elementen im perioden system dass man die wirklich sehen und entdecken konnte,
und dann herausfinden konnte ja mit welcher effizienz erzeugen werden solche sterne elemente eigentlich in den sternen erzeugt.
Eigentlich auch elemente sehen die so auf der erde nicht gibt.
Ja eben wie gesagt das technik das ist halt ein element was nur,
radioaktive iso tope hat dass es nicht an nicht stabiles element,
und das sind also elemente die in stern sind kritisiert werden aber nach einer gewissen zeit wieder zu fallen und wenn,
also in einem stern ein solches element finde dass technik zum weiß ich das ist in diesem stern entstanden vor ich sag mal eine million jahren ansonsten würden wir das nicht mehr sehen.
Und technik sozusagen das leichteste element im perioden system,
was nur instabile iso truppe hat da gibt's jetzt noch andere wie diese ganz schweren elemente aber das ist ein sondern direkt danach weiß dass diese elemente in diesen stern wenn man so will gebacken werden.
Also man sieht da wirklich den den prozess der nukleos synthese der entstehung von von einem schnellen menschen in den sternen.
Das heißt man kann sozusagen richtig diesen objekten dabei zuschauen wie.
Wie das.
Das gefüge unserer materiellen wert welt zusammen gestanzt wird.
Genau das sind so salzburg volle worte.
Das das kann ich,
ja herr weidner vielen vielen dank für die einblicke und auch die ausblicke rund um die weltraum teleskope schauen wir mal was da noch so alles beobachtet wird.
Ja aber bis dahin bedanke ich mich hier wieder fürs zuhören bei raum zeit bald geht's wieder weiter bis dahin sage ich tschüss und.